[MUSIC]
I come from a real simple background.
My mom cleaned houses,
my dad was a Navy mechanic.
They both immigrated from Mexico.
I'm the first of my family
to graduate from College.
Just considering where I come from and
where I'm at today, every day that I
wake up and get to do something here
in this space is like a blessing.
So I don't take it for
granted, and just looking for
something more in the day to day,
more than just a business challenge.
I'm Arnulfo Ventura,
I'm the CEO of Beanfields.
I've been in the food and beverage
industry for the last 12 years, and
GSB class of 2008.
What I learned the most from the GSB
that still serves me well today,
it's that it's the answer to that
question that everybody has to answer
to in the process of applying to the GSB,
is what matters to you most and
why, and not losing sight of that.
[MUSIC]
Beanfields is a company
that started in 2010, and
it was ultimately founded with
the idea of making a better for
you tortilla chip, a chance to
provide an alternative for corn.
And so our products are made
from a composition of navy bean,
black bean and brown rice.
Think of a Doritos, but perhaps healthier.
Still a small company in the neighbourhood
of around 16 direct employees,
a larger extended force in the hundreds.
But all 16 of those members aren't
doing the same job they were doing 12
months ago.
Each and everyone of them is
doing something more, acting
at an elevated position, or even taking on
additional roles and responsibilities that
are setting them for their next kind
of professional step or development.
Brand and
taste come before everything else.
Taste has to absolutely be there, but
the brand has to pop enough at the shelf.
What you have to do really closely is
listen to what the consumer wants,
because the consumer has the power.
And the consumer will be sure with their
dollars to vote one way or another,
but they'll signal what they want.
So what lured me to Beanfields
specifically was just the fact that it
was on a downward trajectory, that they
had already taken a couple of swings at it
with other leaders and
that it quite hadn't gotten there.
So it's like, yeah,
let me let me try that,
see if that seems like a worthy challenge.
And wait, there's also these other
aspects to it, the B Corporation aspect,
the partnership with
farmers in North Dakota and
continue to promote conventional and
organic farming.
Now on the social impact side, the fact
that we get to partner with a nonprofit,
Homeboy Industries,
that's helping to rehabilitate
previously incarcerated gang members.
When you weave in all those pieces, it
certainly makes working here fulfilling.
But I think those are key components
that most brands are aspiring
to include today in developing a food and
beverage brand.
So it's been some time since
I graduated from the GSB.
Fast-forwarding to today and
what matters to me most hasn't changed.
I think the tools and the experiences that
I picked up by the GBS help keep it in
perspective for me, and
they're certainly hard skills.
I think the one that
probably serves me the most,
certainly inter- personal dynamics.
The business part of businesses easy,
it's the people part that's
always the challenge.
Three core things that are coming to
mind that stick with me until this day,
it's how you treat people,
hard work ethic and
take pride in your craft.
[MUSIC]